foreign
hey you know what it's time for it's
time for facts of your friends let's do
it
um
that's the music of like in a movie when
there's a montage and a guy with a
mullet and leather pants like kicks open
the door he has no shirt on he's just
smoking that's that music play it again
foreign
stranger things no
anybody who knows what I'm talking about
Billy from strange stranger things
that's his that's his soundtrack massive
awesome yeah and it's a soundtrack to
factor your friends all right today
we're going to talk about
how to talk about sex with your partner
how to talk about sex how to talk about
sex Let's Talk About Sex baby all right
um a couple articles Kelly gave me here
one is from verywellmind.com one's from
psychologytoday.com
um different different ways to talk
about sex uh with your partner there's
several things in here
um
I have been having this conversation as
you can probably tell in the show in
fact it's funny my wife and I my wife is
talking to me about something oh we're
making uh the questions for humans cards
we're making a sex and intimacy deck and
so I asked my wife to like go through
some of these with me we were talking
through them and she had several
questions that I had written down she
goes don't ask that and I was like why
not and she goes just don't ask it it
makes the whole room weird
and I said I ask you that question I've
asked my friends that question people
come to the house asking those questions
and she goes yes and you've been making
rooms weird for years I was like really
she goes yes all of your friends know it
that you're the most awkward person so
I'm learning in real time
I just will have I just like talk with
everybody about everything and there's
very few if there's no things that are
taboo or weird for me
um I've learned in the last several
years that that's not the case
um with just about anybody and so
I have also learned
um just meeting people all across the
country
um the show especially the calls that
come in the emails that come in
man there are few things going on in
um Western relationships right now like
challenges with sex and intimacy
particularly how to have these
conversations I like this I don't like
this I want to try this and there's so
much wrapped up into these conversations
and there's so much ego there's so much
shame there's so much I don't know
there's so much embarrassment
um we have the data is pretty clear
we've got a we are now there we haven't
a generation of men getting married that
they have received their sexual
education from pornography and so they
understand sex ad they understand sex to
be something that it is not and
um there's very many a whole bunch of
women that have received that over the
not as much as the men the data says but
millions of women have received sex at
or what they think is expected of them
and here and of course those are both
very generalized I know but so here we
find marriages are really struggling I
thought sex was gonna be like this and
she's like I know I thought sex was
gonna be like this and I thought and it
just turned into a quagmire and what we
do in our modern world is we don't have
any tools for talking about things we
just have enough distractions we just go
our separate ways and you've heard me
say this then you find yourself two
inches apart and two thousand miles away
from each other on the couch
um him on his device her on her device
and you're just in different planets
together and so there's something
incredibly profound
and uniting and quite honestly just a
ton of fun
learning how to talk about sex with your
spouse like we're going to talk about
let's just talk about it and it ends up
becoming fun things to talk about silly
things to talk about serious things to
talk about
um but there's just ways to do it right
and so
um these two articles give a couple of
ideas um we'll link to them in the show
notes um they're not really scientific
if you will it's just some best
practices here
um there is a couple of things that come
from some data that I can that I'll I'll
bring out but here is
what I'm going to suggest here's several
I wrote down seven things
seven rules if you will for talking
about sex with your spouse the Romantic
party
um here's number one set specific times
to have this conversation designated
say the words we're going to talk about
sex on Friday
we're gonna go to dinner and talk about
sex we're gonna talk about sex on
Saturday on a long walk where we're
sitting next to each other and we don't
even have to look at each other in the
eye but we're going to talk about it
we're going to practice that way
don't spring it on somebody or when you
get frustrated or you don't feel self I
mean you're feeling self-conscious and
you take your shirt off man I'm talking
about male or female and it's like do
you think I'm attractive do you know or
what's that old joke like you know
you're rolling over to go to sleep and
then one of you you know your wife Taps
you on the shoulder and she's like if I
didn't have any arms and legs but you
still want to be with me like don't do
that that's not a productive
conversation that's a way to get a
reaction out of somebody and this is not
a great conversation for reactions it's
a good conversation to have um when
everybody knows it's coming and we are
prepared for it so set a specific time
um if you need to like set it up like
Hey we're gonna talk about budgets and
then we're going to talk about this and
we're going to talk about the state of
our sex life it might be a five minute
conversation it might be a 20 minute
conversation that would be two hours
great
um and by the way you think when you've
been married three years that you've
talked about everything you haven't
things begin to shift and morph and hey
I heard about this and I saw all this
and remember that couple in that movie
yesterday do you want to try that or
what did you think about that or that
was weird I heard this at work the
conversations will continue to evolve if
you make it a regular part of your
relationship interaction so set specific
times number two own the awkwardness
the more you own the awkwardness start
the conversation this is gonna be weird
or this is going to be awkward or I've
never talked about
uh I've never talked about my body parts
with somebody else before I've never
admitted this before I've never talked
about masturbation with somebody else
before I've never talked about this my
number of partners with somebody I've
never talked about owning just own the
awkwardness just own it this is gonna be
awkward and then as you speak in into a
like a uh you speak these things out
into the world you're honest about these
things often for the first time out loud
and you're telling them to somebody who
has looked you in the eye and told your
friends and your community and your
families and God if you're a religious
person I will always be here I won't
leave you
and then you can begin to have these
honest real deep conversations about
yeah this is kind of what I'm into this
is what I'm about this is what I like I
wish I didn't have this past but I do or
I wish I experienced this thing
own the awkwardness okay that's number
two it's gonna be weird
good
number three
be specific
God Almighty we've got so many words for
so many different body parts and some we
talk in circles about you know it's kind
of really
here's what I mean I don't like it when
your tongue does XYZ
or whenever you kiss me you do it too
hard
I don't I wish you kissed me gentler or
hey try this or can we try this or I
love it when
I love when you touch me here when there
are dishes and by the way it doesn't
have to be just about body parts such
and body parts when there are dishes in
the sink
I my body can't fully relax
when you and I are fighting and I know
we had put a little star on today on the
calendar when we're having a fight I
just can't get into it
um we need to have this conversation
first
so be specific and practice being
specific I like this thing and for many
of you when you say I like this thing
you're going to turn beat red your
heart's gonna start beating all weird
and especially
ah when I say I don't like this thing
which leads me to number four
practice this
practice
not getting your feelings hurt
when your husband when your wife tells
you I don't like this
and they do it in a loving way obviously
they can be mean about it and be cruel
but when somebody tells you in a loving
way
they are giving you insights into their
soul into the things that bring them
happiness in eroticism and pleasure and
joy
rejoice in the fact that you've got some
new data some new tools like some new
ideas for moving forward and that you're
not doing something that your partner
doesn't like because if you're doing
something they don't like or in a way
they don't like
if you put on a cologne and you get like
your leather vest and no shirt you're
like yeah and you like shave a mustache
and you're like this it's it's party
time weekend and you put that music on
they were just playing
and your wife is like oh God
I hate and then sex is weird and it's
awkward and you're all super weird and
the music you're playing is awful like
wouldn't you rather
hey when you
like go down that road it makes me so
uncomfortable it makes me think about X
or why or it makes me feel this way I
would love to try this
and then
man you can be into it and she could be
into it everybody can be into it and it
changes all Dynamic so I this is
generalized statement okay this applies
to more than just men but
more men than I hear from women whenever
I say hey I would like to try this or
instead of this can we try this that men
get their feelings so hurt guys can be
the worst with their egos like and they
got their sex from pornography so they
think sex supposed to be like this
and it's not
it's not
and
so Men set your ego down
and women set your ego down
this is about learning and listening and
trying to honor your partner this isn't
about being right or this is the way we
oh man
no hurt feelings okay the best if
somebody's cruel and they try to hurt
your feelings well you suck at this or
my old boyfriend used to do this better
than well yes you should have your
feelings hurt because someone's just
being cruel
okay
um so be curious be curious
um
I don't
we may have to edit this out okay
along the hurt feelings I remember
talking talking to
um
ah
I was talking to a couple ones several
years ago
she thought she was
amazing and
with a particular move that she had
according to him the move was not
amazing it was awful it was so painful
and
he didn't want to hurt anybody's
feelings it just kind of like was like
and just endured it until finally he
started to stop start avoiding sexual
contact altogether
I'm only laughing because listening to
them tell the story was a riot they're
both super funny people
um
and she said the greatest gift she
received was when he said you have to
stop doing that because it hurts so bad
stop and she was like what and then when
she found out that she wasn't hurting
him anymore
that was a gift to her and yes she was
embarrassed like crazy I can't believe
this went off forever and she was also
kind of pissed you let this go on this
long without telling me this hurt
instead of us was an awesome yes I did I
was embarrassed and then that kind of
set the stage for you we're just gonna
talk about everything because there's no
reason to just endure this this way
right so there you go
um all right number five don't
replay or dig for performance reviews
don't like after a sexual encounter
don't be like all right was that an A or
a b or a c is that Varsity moves don't
do that
this is about relationship stuff now if
you want to compliments your partner
great if you want to when you're talking
about it a couple of days later or a
week later
um hey the other night that was
incredible or hey I said I would try
this thing one time I did not dig it I
didn't dig it it wasn't great it wasn't
fun
um I'm not super interested in doing
that again what did you think I loved it
uh well like man I'm glad you did but it
wasn't I wasn't into it
um when you start Play by playing in the
moment
um the act of sex itself is such a
vulnerable intimate engagement
right afterwards is such a release of
neurological chemicals it's a physical
it is not a time for Learning and for uh
critique
it's a moment for
and so if you're is critique to be given
if there's conversations to be had a
take critique out of it and if you are
insecure about hey did you like that
what did you think about that the number
of people who have told me I can't stand
it will my husband and wife asked me how
was it what'd you think was it pretty
awesome don't do that don't do that
create an environment in your
relationship where they'll let you know
I'll tell you I mean it was it was
awesome do we need to go down the I
thought you knew it was awesome when I
was yelling or I was smiling or I was
like whatever was going on in in in
there at the time
so
um don't dig for performance reviews
okay be at peace and if something's
awesome if you're part of something new
or something Incredible or awesome or
whatever's meaningful or felt right or
you felt super connected say that say
that and by the way again it doesn't
have to be about some sex thing it can
be hey last night start to finish
you helped out with bedtime with the
kids
man you just went like it helped really
helped out with the with the uh
dishes I got to take a long bath it was
incredible dude the whole night I felt
super connected I felt seen I felt loved
I felt it just connected say those
things those are awesome six have soup
tons of fun have fun with the
conversations okay have fun
um ask each other about fantasies what's
like a thing you've never told anybody
that you you would never do it but you
would like I'd want to know I don't know
what to be like
um what are some things that like I
heard about this once like have you ever
heard about it like have those come that
can be so fun it can be erotic in itself
having the conversation like oh my gosh
my wife is talking to me about this my
husband's talking about yes have those
conversations
um I've talked about this on the show
The Erotic envelope system it's
sometimes hard
to say hey
honey I want to try this particular sex
move or I want to try this particular
that's hard it's awkward it's weird so
uh the idea was get 10 envelopes for 50
cents at Walmart or Walgreens and you
take five and she takes five or vice
versa and you write down I want to try
this
and I just want to try it it
the rule is you got to be curious not
judgmental you can't be like oh my gosh
you sick for unless unless it's like
whoa whoa right but
be like what what okay I don't know how
how this works I don't know how we can
make this happen I'm in I'm down
um I'm just curious tell me about it
tell me about like the talk about what
you want and everyone listening to this
you have a thing they just pop into your
head that's why I'm not telling you uh a
couple of ideas because I just want you
to go with whatever just popped into
your head
um and sometimes it's I'll just tell you
like me and my wife did this we
one of hers was french kissing
I miss just french kissing
and I was like
uh okay
so we french kissed and it was kind of
awesome it was awesome it was awesome
and okay last one
um
over the course of this conversation
be honest about pain
about past hurts if you are a abuse
Survivor and there's a context of safety
in your relationship in your marriage or
if you're with the counselor be honest
about things that bring you pain
discomfort that make you
um feel less than
okay whether that's a request for a
particular sex act whether that is a way
your partner's approaching you whether
that's a way like whatever like be
honest about things happen in your past
be honest about pain okay and I made
light of it earlier
um just because that particular
situation the two people are hilarious
but there's a lot of time Pain's not
funny at all not even a little bit
in fact it's disturbing and someone
needs to raise a flag and say hey I'm
not comfortable with this this hurt stop
or this reminds me of the way a former
girlfriend talked to me and it makes me
super uncomfortable a former boyfriend
used to do like I'd stop stop right
um be very honest about your pain okay
so that's seven
seven things seven ways you can talk
about sex with your partner please make
this a regular part of 2023 for you and
like for you and your spouse like talk
about it talk about it talk about it
man having the conversations be willing
to be curious so judgmental having fun
with this man you can change your life